there's been a lot of talk recently
about banning bitcoin but i don't think
that's such a smart idea actually i
think it's pretty stupid and here's why
bitcoin is an open digital decentralized
peer-to-peer network very similar to the
internet and what we saw decades ago is
as the internet was created and began to
become pervasive across the world
countries had a choice am i going to
lean in am i going to adopt this
technology am i going to hand it to my
citizens or instead am i going to be
abrasive and cut my citizens access to
the internet off well we saw countries
like the united states lean in and say
if anyone's going to use the internet
we're going to be a leader in that space
we're going to benefit more than anybody
else and it turned out pretty good for
the united states we're now the home of
innovation and technology around the
world but then there was other countries
like north korea that decided to be
abrasive and to literally cut their
citizens access to the internet off
didn't turn out so hot for those
countries and so we're seeing the same
thing play out again when it comes to
bitcoin bitcoin is that open
decentralized digital peer-to-peer
network and some countries are going to
be abrasive and other countries are
going to lean in and adopt it don't take
it from me though take it from russia's
finance minister anton silanov here's
the quote of exactly what he said he
said the central bank wants to take and
ban crypto assets cryptocurrencies
arguing that this creates risks
primarily for citizens that it can
infect financial institutions banks and
create an opaque settlement market this
is the same as banning the internet
which is impossible now remember we saw
that the central bank of russia they
wanted to ban bitcoin cryptocurrencies
the trading the holding of those assets
they were talking about this all the way
back in january but then in february we
got an agreement the government vladimir
putin and others came together with the
central bank and they reached that
agreement to allow for the regulation of
cryptocurrencies which was developed by
the ministry of finance instead of
having a complete ban again rather than
ban it they created rules and they said
we're going to actually go ahead and
regulate it that's a pretty smart idea
because if we look at actual the growth
rate of the internet compared to crypto
users what we find is that crypto is
growing at about the same pace of the
internet this is a really big deal it's
a big technology it's going to be
adopted around the world it quite
literally is going to end up being the
backbone of an entire new digital
financial system if you ban it you're
basically going to be like north korea
you're going to cut your citizens access
off from an important technology that
actually can bring economic prosperity
jobs freedom and innovation but if you
go ahead and you lean in and you adopt
it you can be a leader of this new world
the united states hopefully is going to
lean in it looks like russia is going to
lean in we see other places like el
salvador leaning in and ultimately what
we are going to get is we're going to
get a bifurcation on the global stage
the countries that adopt bitcoin the
countries that go ahead and empower
their citizens the countries that
realize that bitcoin is good for
business and then everybody else if
you're a country if you're a politician
if you're a government lean in adopt
bitcoin understand that you can't ban it
understand that you can't shut down the
system bitcoin is inevitable and whether
you decide to adopt it or not it's going
to continue to produce block after block
after block of transactions bitcoin is
good for business and ultimately every
single country is going to adopt it hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time